education of the principle of equal pay
for equal work or work of equal value
between
men and women
I'd also like to welcome the
commissioner welcome
to our session
I'd like to begin by giving the floor to
our colleague Kira Maria Peter Hansen
now you have the floor as the reporter
please go ahead
thank you chair idea commissioner dear
Council and dear colleagues
today we're here voting on a historical
and essential piece of legislation we're
here because we stand against pay
discrimination we stand again power
abuses and because equal pay for equal
work should not only be a founding
principle in our treaties but also a
fact on the ground
we're here because we care we want to
make a change we want to push for gender
equality workers rights and social
progress we want a future where there's
inclusion and diversity
today we are here to vote on the best
known tool for closing the gender paper
to combat gender pay inequalities and
pay discrimination
the patrons parent directive is a huge
achievement for gender equality and it
will help close the current persistent
gender pay Gap in the European Union on
14 percent
patrons parent has the value of work at
its Center because employees should be
valued for their work regardless of
their gender
with this vote we abolish pay secrecy
contract we strengthen workers rights
and workers individual rights
information and we ask employers to
report and to fix their pay gaps
furthermore we ensure that all employers
have pay structures in place ensuring
that the treaty-based concept of equal
pay for equal work is actually enforced
with this vote we Empower workers and we
strengthen the role of social partners
this road also marks the first time in
history that our non-binary friends are
recognized in legislation and the first
time that we take into account
intersectional discrimination as an
aggravating Factor
and this is a historical moment not only
because having these tools and
mechanisms are huge achievement but also
because this sends a message to the
world it shows that this is what
legislation can look like when you have
two young feminists leading the policies
and and
for that I would like to deeply thank my
colleague Samira for the hard work and
incredible cooperation in the past two
years you're truly an inspiring
politician and it's been amazing working
alongside you and your team
and on behalf of Samir and I would also
like to give a special thanks to to all
the Shadow repertoires and all the teams
for your constant fight for GNA quality
I would like to thank the commission as
well for putting forward this
legislation and supporting us in getting
it over the finish line
lastly a special thing should go to the
tech presidency without you and without
this presidency we would not have been
able to vote on this important file
today
and I cannot fully express my gratitude
towards the Czech presidency but I would
like to underline that I'm extremely
grateful that your presidency and your
team chose to take on this file and
really walk the extra mile to make this
a reality
and coming from Denmark it's also very
nice to see that it is once again proven
that smaller countries can have a huge
impact on European lawmaking
lastly I would also like to thank our
amazing teams as the Julia Claire Hoban
Yeti and Blanca and the contribution and
expertise of ngos and social partners
that participated and worked on this
file your work was and is extremely
essential and valuable
with today's vote we will be one step
closer in ensuring that there are no
more glass ceilings and no more pay
discrimination today we give more rides
for workers and we ensure the concept of
equal pay for equal work thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and I'd like to give
the floor to the co-wraport Samira
Rafaela
and good morning dear colleagues good
morning commissioner today we will make
history I am incredibly proud to stand
in this house and to say to all women in
Europe we are here for you in fact we
can say this to all workers in Europe
This directive says you deserve to be
treated equally and you deserve to be
paid fairly regardless of your gender
your background or your physical
characteristics with this directive we
have secured the right to information in
Europe for all our citizens and we will
finally have The Binding legislation we
need to tackle paid discrimination in
all our member states if we had left it
up to the markets the gender pay Gap
would only correct Itself by 2086. how
could we justify this to women how could
we explain this to ourselves
we cannot and for far too long the
economy has been organized with man in
mind women were not the norm and you can
see this in the representation of women
in leadership positions in the pay Gap
in the pension Gap there is a structural
problem here and we can't just smash the
glass ceiling we need to rebuild the
entire house
and today we are doing exactly that
desvets loan transparency kept Olive
flower in Europa the hunt foreign
women in Europe need to be paid
same manner
it should not be a situation where you
find that a man who is receiving more um
uh pay for a similar post for the same
post this is a legal framework to work
to fight against uh the pay Gap in a
clear and Relentless Manner and we will
achieve this paradigm shift and we will
achieve uh equality in the workplace
women who are not paid the same level by
the businesses these businesses will not
move forward businesses need to prove
that there has been no paid
discrimination the burden of proof has
been put on businesses now and I'm
extremely proud of the fact that we have
this modern European legislation for the
first time non-binary people are
explicitly
um quoted as and we also recognize
intersectional discrimination in case
law will take it into account as a
serious factor in paid discrimination it
was
it was a very important point for me and
here I'm here in politics to change the
rules and this is a rule that we have
changed we are in politics to ensure
that emancipation is a reality
I know there are those in this chamber
who will vote against the directive I
know they will hide behind certain words
as administrative burden the reality is
that women in Europe are looking at us
now and they will remember this vote and
they will they will remember that you've
put the interest of business before the
interests of women so you need to tell
that into account
I'm extremely proud of my colleague Kira
we have been leading these negotiations
with thank you very much for your
support together we have shown uh that
this inclusive modern legislation yes
Claire Julia mirta hasta Laura and hoba
but negotiation team from all political
groups
because today we will make history
together and I am glad that we could
constructively work together with the
French presidency with the Czech
presidency with the commission we have
showed that if that if we want to reach
through equality for all people living
in Europe that we need to work together
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor for the European commission
the commissioner Helen Darley please
thank you president honorable members
good morning today's adoption of the pay
transparency directive is a significant
step towards addressing the gender pay
Gap and the European Union and
increasing women's economic and
financial Independence
equal pay between women and men for
equal work or work of equal value is
their right and shrined in the treaty
and contributes towards the fundamental
principle of gender equality in the
European Union
despite the eu's rights and our efforts
the gender pay Gap has for decades
remained a persistent problem with women
in the EU earning an average of 13 less
than men
while the gender breakup has many causes
a large part of it is due to pay
discrimination and gender bias
we cannot allow women
to be paid less for doing the same work
or work of equal value as men
we cannot allow women to be
discriminated against in the workplace
because of our gender
we cannot continue undervaluing women's
contribution on the labor market
compared to men
pay discrimination is often the result
of an undervaluation of work done by
women or of unconscious bias and deeply
rooted gender stereotypes
they all continue to persist in our
society and because of the current lack
of pay transparency they often go
unnoticed
the pay transparency directive is a
crucial tool in our fight for gender
equality this new legal framework will
trigger a culture change in the
workplace across the Union
it will require employers to provide
information on average pay levels broken
down by gender for all workers
performing the same job or work of equal
value and this will enable workers to
identify and challenge any pay
discrimination based on sex
the directive will also require
employers with more than 100 workers to
publish information on the gender pay
Gap in their organization it will
increase transparency and accountability
and encourage employers to take action
to close the pay Gap
having the information on pay or gender
pay gaps is not enough of course workers
must also have the possibility to
enforce their right to equal pay if they
believe they are being discriminated
this is why the directive provides for
stronger enforcement mechanisms for
instance the directive will ensure that
victims of pay discrimination can be
represented in court by relevant
associations and bodies such as equality
bodies it will also ensure better
compensation shift the burden of proof
and set minimum standards for limitation
periods
I draw your attention to a transposition
period of three years for the entry into
application of the new rules on pay
transparency
during the negotiations the commission
underlined that such longer period
a deviation from a standard two-year
transposition period should not be seen
as a precedent it only aims at ensuring
that employers will have
non-discriminatory pay structures in
place so as to ensure full application
of the new rules at the time of
transposition
such commission statement was included
in the minutes of the meeting of member
states Deputy permanent Representatives
when the political agreement was
endorsed on the 21st of December of last
year
I thank European Parliament specially
Samir Kira and the others who who you
mentioned for the continued support and
determination to combat gen the pay
gender-based paid discrimination your
commitment to gender equality has been
invaluable and the development and
negotiation of this legislation the
adoption of the pay transparency
directive will be a significant
achievement in our fight for gender
equality it is a step towards the Europe
where women and all their diversity can
Thrive equally thank you
thank you
very good thank you very much and now
I'd like to give the floor to the first
of the political speakers we'll have
around political speakers we'll begin
with our colleague from the Epp Maria
Walsh please good morning colleagues
commissioner
um what a day
today uh the gender pay Gap in the EU
stands at just under 13 12.7 but this
directive is going to change that
this pay Gap remains unexplained for
many and cannot be linked to the
individual worker education or working
time and we need this directive as
greater levels of pay transparency will
uncover unjustified
gender-based differences and empower the
victims many victims of pay
discrimination to seek redress
our workers need the tools to compare
salaries and ensure that they are paid
equally for the work that they do and
this directive is that tool
with Ireland celebrating its 50th
Anniversary as a member of the EU we can
reflect on the leading role the EU has
played in striving for gender equality
we must not forget that it was the EU
law when we signed in 1973 which forced
Ireland to abolish the marriage bar
an unjust piece of legislation which
which pushed thousands of Irish women
out of the workforce based solely on
their marriage status
today that struggle for gender equality
reaches another milestone
it's time we finally deliver on the
Promises of equal pay a founding
principle of the European Union since
the 1957 Treaty of Rome we as a European
Parliament must legislate for income
equality and eradicate the gender pay
Gap once and for all
ladies watching and sitting in the
chamber particularly those up here in
the gallery this today does not have to
be an exception it has to be the norm
in about a year's time we will go to the
polls at European level at many Irish
Country Irish Country myself in many
European countries will ask people to
put their names forward for local
elections this is the time to see the 50
percent in this chamber and across the
European Union let this not be the
exception let this be the norm thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much and I'd like to give
the floor for the s d group for the vice
president of the European Parliament
Evelyn Regner please
thank you soon thank you very much yeah
we will be closing the gender pay Gabba
This is historic day because this
transparency directive
will change people's lives
David Anna and Kim
because this affects all of our Lives
after many years of negotiations we have
agreement on this paid transparency
directive it's a fundamental it's a
foundation for women's rights and it's
important step
for uh for an issue which is important
for women and trade unions I'm very
proud of this very constructive team
that have worked on this directive
together I'm very happy that this demand
from the social Democrats is now
becoming reality the beginning of this
Parliament
we said to the commission President we
want and we need this directive and now
we have it here thanks to this fantastic
Corporation so thank you Kira and Samira
all female employees will have the
opportunity to receive the pay
information each year and this
transparency will allow
the systematic Port pay of women to be
to be brought to an end not just
salaries but also company cars and other
fringe benefits often it's these fringe
benefits that makes the difference women
will find it easier to know how much
they will be earning and they'll be uh
they'll through protection protective
mechanisms they'll be able to enforce
their rights
this will allow all employees to talk
about their wages and salaries
openly especially with trade unions so
this brings all the secrecy to an end
all everybody should earn what they
deserve thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker for
renew group is
thank you president 13
this is the pay gap between men and
women across the European Union
this figure shows all of the
inequalities the difficult situations
and the European Union is going to put
end to this
um difference we owe this we offer
thanks to Akira Samira and the
negotiating teams thank you and
congratulations and specifically thank
you to civilian who unfortunately cannot
be with us here today uh your struggle
our struggle is something we've brought
to this chamber it's a fight for equal
uh pay uh pay gaps are no longer
acceptable
this is a fight for emancipation because
it's also a financial Independence it's
a necessity that we will guarantee this
is a fight for inclusion because when
we're seeing regression of women's
rights across the European Union this
directive will ensure that businesses
take their responsibility to build this
fight for equality between women and men
thank you to everyone
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker
Catherine logancepen one minute please
thank
you thank you very much dear Helena dear
colleagues
dear citizens
up in the audience history is being made
we're making progress and today we're
making progress by ending discrimination
very often
it's said to women well
what you're just imagining this
discrimination where does it how can you
prove that men uh earn more than women
prove it and we're ending that today
so women
with different backgrounds
don't have to prove this no we're
turning it around the Enterprise the
other side has to prove that men and
women are what they're earning
and no I don't think this was a bad
negotiation it was just
it was just wage discrimination it was
not something imagined it wasn't
incompetence with negotiating for wages
so this is we're making progress we're
ending the pay Gap and we're doing that
today for women in the EU
[Applause]
thank you very much and now for the the
European conflicting performance groups
the president commissioner colleagues
once again using excuse of supposed
equality to generate uh inequality even
Between Women some of you call this
intersectionality I call it Injustice
this is just a slogan directive where
the title has nothing to do with what
you want to impose on us you're not
seeking gender equality you want to
introduce gender ideology into our laws
you want to force member states to do
things you want to dominate companies
and our lives
for a situation where Talent will not be
recognized meanwhile European companies
workers and families already treated
poorly by the green deal there's
inflation there's a suffocating red tape
now they also need to comply with a poor
regulation which will
um lead to a number of disputes for this
reason I have uh on behalf of my group
introduced a motion to reject this and I
am I invite you to follow this because
if you're in favor of progress for men
and women in the EU and not left-wing
Democrat demagogy you should be able to
follow this thank you
thank you very much and now I'd like to
give the floor
to the IND group at Christie nunsen
please
EU Parliament once again is making
everyone fight one another in other
words to divide and Rule and by making
these demands for pay you can now know
what everyone earns and then you're
going to end up with the cases of envy
and a poisoned work environment there
are
if there are male colleagues where you
could adjust the wage if there aren't
any men then you have imaginary men in
order to adjust the potential wage and
so if there isn't any wage
discrimination then you can just insist
that there's a theoretical possibility
of having wage discrimination in order
to assert claims so you're completely
intoxicated with equality I'm really
have to question this
what are you thinking who is tying your
shoes every morning
foreign
thank you very much and I'd like to give
the floor to the left group
you're on the floor
thank you very much uh president uh 70
years ago supposedly women achieved
equality however the pay graph continues
in the European Union now as we know
opacity is part of the problem this
directive finally recognizes the right
to information for all workers is a
major so therefore it's a major step
forward the surprising point is it's
been so difficult to get to this point
we have lacked ambition and we're still
behind the curve part of the obligation
of this directive is for information on
the pay gap on unfortunately it leaves
out 99 to European businesses because it
only forces those businesses with over a
hundred members of staff and only in
eight years time and we know that for
the commission and the council we
wouldn't be talking about one percent of
European business but it'll be 0.2
percent of business so we have made a
step forward but we're still very far uh
behind the Spanish legislation for
example where we have more Progressive
rules the threshold is 50 workers with
uh and they also have to provide
equality plans and this hasn't created
additional
um burden it created a business
environment which is uh better in Spain
with in in Europe we have this
requirement to move forward but we still
need to continue moving forward
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor
uh to non-attacked remember Adam causa
thank you very much
our goal is to ensure that
we ensure equality for men and women
when it comes to salaries however the
mistakes in this directive because
it does forced issues that are the focus
of liberals
the draft
directive
is not in line with the treaty and the
functioning of the European Union
and I therefore will not vote in favor
of this draft legislation for years we
have been working to ensure that women
receive the same wages as men and
if we when we could actually reach that
goal
but it's not about having one model for
payment
no
it it is absurd the way this directive
is being being drafted we are
legislators
voters
want us to to end differences in wages
between men and women and this is what
we should focus on nothing else
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor
to serper in two minutes please
discrimination is not allowed in our
treatise
it is uh denied by the Equal Pay
directive
somehow after tens of years of existence
in the EU we still lack
both in the equal pay for equal work and
not to talk about equal value
the 30 percent on salvation women
this is not acceptable
what you do not know you cannot act upon
and this is the reason why this pay
transparency directive is so important
it gives the possibilities for employers
and employees
to have the full picture what is the
legal funds and basis for their salary
based on the competence on the
demandness of the work and other special
qualifications
not the trend
and this gives the first possibility to
really see where we stand and to take
the positive access
it's important that it is Criminal to
discriminate in concrete
by Gent
I find it extremely important that by
this directive we are going to have the
harmonized criteria indicators and
application systems developed by Aegis
together with the commission
this is just the comparability between
different Industries member states
public and private sectors
so we actually know where we stand
it is important that the Commissioners
Parliament asks reviews the directive
within due time so to how to see to
expand its coverage because now it is
covering less than one percent of the
Enterprises and 50 percent of the
workers so that it covers all the
workers and all the employers
and maybe active equality programming
and eradication of these problems could
be included in this review thank you
all right
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
from vice president Mark Angel the
president the commissioner dear
colleagues uh print the principle of
equal pay for equal work is enshrined in
our treaty since 1957 and this is not an
invention as we often hear from the
anti-gender ideologists from the right
side that this is an idea an idea from
feminists this is this is in our treaty
and um we are fighting for Union of
equality and you are defending
patriarchy that's the difference
um 2000 2012 we had recommendations the
commission came up with recommendations
some countries followed these
recommendations and the gender pay get
close in these countries so this is
again an example that often
recommendations is not enough we need
legislation and I'm happy that we get
this legislation today for the s d group
it was very important that this
directive will work for all women the
women in small companies and in bigger
companies unfortunately the threshold is
now companies of 100 who have to report
annually but we were able to bring it
down from 250 to 100 and we were all
able together to strengthen the
individual rights of workers in this
directive which is very important so
this directive is now working for all
the women and remember it was the women
during covet who brought us through
tough times the women in the
supermarkets the women in the hospitals
who worked very hard and who made the
whole the whole society a function so
I'm very happy also that these
individual rights are very strengthened
Trade union rights are strengthened also
and we have the the shift of the burden
of proof on pay related issues
um the burden of proof will shift from
the worker to the employer but I'm very
proud also on the gender inclusive
language which we put in there this
directive works for women and men in all
that adversity we're out of this binary
view we are in a linear view there's a
diversity of men there is a diversity of
women this has been stated by by ruling
from the ecj and therefore it's good
that this is a modern legislation thank
you very much to the two young feminists
rapporters Samira and and Kiera and I'm
proud as an old feminist male feminist
also to have been participating in this
I want to thank also my good cooperation
with Evelyn Regner in the snd team our
team was fantastic too so we did great
teamwork together and we did something
for the women in our European Union
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much I now like to give
the floor to dragos please letter one
minute please
thank you very much
um president commissioner
colleagues
often
we are asked
what do you do in the European
Parliament to help citizens every time I
go back to Romania people ask me that
what kind of positive change will you
bring about in our lives well a specific
example
is this directive
for equal pay for men and women
we have been speaking for 60 years about
values and principles that we are not
putting into practice women in Romania
earn less than men and when they retire
the situations even worse this
legislative initiative will have a
direct impact on citizens lives
especially women's lives and it will
combat discrimination
everyone will earn the same for equal
work and this directive will improve
women's Financial situations but it will
also have a positive impact on the whole
of society I would like to thank Samira
and Kira
to all colleagues who were shutter
operators on this file
and I'm very grateful that I was able to
be part of that team thank you
Ricardo
thank you very much and I'd like to give
the floor to elsevier terravanska
is
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
tell you about the situation of women in
my country in Poland as regards a pay
Gap
in Poland the country that is being so
frequently attacked in the parliament
this Gap amounts to 4.5 percent
we rank second only to Luxembourg and
Slovenia so Poland is very high up is
ranking very high on this list as
regards the public sector we have a
negative pay gap of 0.6 percent whereas
in the private sector we rank at the
European average which is 13 percent
as regards women aged 55 to 64. we have
a positive
difference favoring women six percent in
construction industry nine percent and
transport and warehousing is also mainly
staffed with women
I'm saying this in order to underscore
the fact that we do have member states
which have been driving towards gender
equality
prior to any directives in this respect
I do believe that we can do better and I
believe that this directive will be
helpful indeed thank you
thank you very much we have a blue card
sorry
colleague
you
you have a blue card I wonder if you
want to reply
you got a blue card from Margarita
Marcus from the snd group do you want to
reply
foreign
thank you Mr President I wanted to ask a
question but firstly I'd like to thank
all those colleagues who have been
involved in this directive this proposal
that we're discussing today I'd also
like to thank the commissioner for her
work on this the path to get to here
that has allowed us to get to here is
linked to the fight of feminists they've
been trying to reduce the pay gap
between women and men what we have just
heard is situation in one country the
European Parliament does not legislate
for one country it legislates further
European union and the question is dear
colleague do you feel comfortable with a
13 average pay grab across the EU
you got afford to reply
I'm fully aware of the situation and the
diversification of the pay situation of
men and women in various member states
there is a huge difference between the
pay Gap in Luxembourg and for instance
in the wealthy countries such as Germany
France and the Netherlands
from 0.75 percent up to 218 or even 22
percent so hence we have this average of
13. and I understand that we wish to
minimize the pay Gap but let me
underscore the fact that there are some
member states which have been conducting
their own social policy also in other
areas without
the obligations imposed by from the
European Union you based on their own
National strategies I do appreciate the
work of our Parliament but I would like
to shed some light and I would like to
highlight what is done in the individual
member states and appreciate that thank
you
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor to Anders visterson for a
minute
we experience
once and again then we look at good
cases where we're going to solve
problems that we end up with this
excessive bureaucracy bureaucracy that
lays down a lot of rules and costs for
companies with the result of uh trying
to reduce this uh Jen Duke have it's
doubtful that that will achieve this so
the parliament should be look
should be not looking at things that are
best dealt with in the National member
states as a Dane I'm very concerned to
see how the EU moves into areas of
social rights of employment rights
in Denmark we have a Danish model which
has proved proved to be much better than
what you're proposing here that
politicians and
shouldn't should be not determining how
you can solve these Solutions it should
be up to the social partners and the
workers to deciding that so you have to
if you have a good if you want to see a
well-functioning system you should look
at Denmark where you don't have this
overburdened bureaucracy but you have
good agreements
sorry click you've got a blue card if
you want to answer is Mr pizzlaro
yeah I mean dear colleague you've
mentioned the fact that things should be
applied at National level I have opened
the statistics looking in Denmark the
pay Gap in Denmark is 12.7 percent
is that the way you like things to
happen in Denmark I mean is that a proof
that you are bringing forward that the
situation is perfect if you are for
which I understand from your declaration
that you are for equal pay for equal
work then why in Denmark the situation
is like that this is exactly why we need
the common action of the European level
thank you
no Mr Anders visiting to respond
s the paradoxical situation is that
legislation could have solved it it
would have solved it already it's
forbidden to discriminate according to
gender in Denmark for many years so if
we could have solved this by having new
legislation in this Parliament and with
more bureaucracy why wasn't this solved
30 years ago and one of the biggest uh
Danish unions
has determined that there is a gender
pay Gap
but they can't Define how they want to
solve it so that's why I don't believe
in this bureaucratic method of solving
this so if you're it depends whether
you're a European federalist or you
believe in the European nations to solve
this problem best thank you
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor to our colleague Sylvia modic
please performance
president for the for Equal Pay equal
for equal work that's a self-evident
question but it's still not functioning
still the pay can be significant between
the genders it's been the same over
years and therefore this proposal on
patrons despite its defaults and
shortcomings is a big step forward
thanks to the parliament directive
obligates more companies to pay
transparency than the proposal by the
commission and it's particularly nice
that for the first time we mentioned
intersectional discrimination when you
take a holistic view of a person this is
indispensable so as to tackle the root
causes of the problem because equal pay
requires more than this directive still
women bear the biggest brand of care
work to take care of homes and fathers
are not spending that much time with the
children and media for instance is very
gender based so we have to get rid of
this because it is
there there are no hobbies for boys and
girls or works for women and men there
are hobbies and there are work and
therefore we have to pay the same pay
for the same work despite the gender or
sex thank you
thank you very much and I like to give
the floor to lucasforless for a minute
and a half
thank you sir good morning everyone
commissioner I would like to thank the
reporters for the great work we are
making an important step today because
if we want to talk about the Europe of
equality this pay gap between men and
women cannot be accepted not only is it
unacceptable it is really sad and
insulting for all of us that came here
with the vote of the European citizens
let's look at some data women in the EU
are paid 13 less than men there are huge
gaps from country to Country
we have 30 percent of women working
part-time whereas it's eight percent of
men women work more hours uh per week
one third of them has to stop working in
order to take care of the children that
and other data prove that equal work for
Equal Pay is not a fact today in the EU
and if it's not a fact we cannot talk
about an EU of equality and equality
before the law
we cannot do enough to stop this
situation so there's still a lot of
things we have to do and we have to be
United thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker
Gabriela Bischoff
good morning good morning colleagues
good morning commissioner dolly many
have said this already this is an
historic day and this Parliament has
done excellent work and why I believe on
the right side there are a few people
who said oh no only this only creates
bureaucracy they don't have an
understood the life reality of of women
in all of their diversity and for that
reason women in Europe looking at this
debate they see that we are looking and
I'm very happy to hear Mrs rafelska
saying these words that we have
countries where it works we have
countries where it work where there's
it's important for me as someone who
comes from the country where there
always has been a gender pay
discrimination it's good to know that it
works it's no we can pull away the veil
and look at this pull away the secrecy
which is the reason that so many women
have such a difficult path to achieve
wage equality and we have instruments
for representatives of workers for work
councils this gives us tools for work to
remove this veil of secrecy and we we
will achieve this thank you
yes Gabrielle you got a blue card
okay so
um
Mr ronkai you got it from
okay thank you but uh
I have a question to you if I'm my
Germans German politicians have very
often said that polls are not tolerant
and that we are a little bit backward in
this in this respect so I would like to
know what the German politicians have
done in the same time
we see a very negative situation of
women in Germany you are out of the rule
of law in Germany why are you pointing
your finger at Poland and why can you
accept that you know very little about
Poland and you create keep criticizing
Poland so Germans are in such a poor
situation
dear colleague if you had listened to me
then you wouldn't have asked such a dumb
question I have to say I praised Poland
and I said for us it's our hope that
there are countries where it's working
out and it shows that it can happen
without destroying the economy if you
have equal pay for equal work and the
women in Germany women from unions women
from different parties from women's
organizations they're all fighting for
that and they're looking they're happy
about the fact that we're achieving what
they've been fighting for and for that
reason it's a good day for women in
Europe for gender equality and it's also
a good day for Europe
[Applause]
uh colleagues let me recall that there
are translation facilities here in the
podium so when there is a blue card you
can hear the translation here in the
podium and in an event you should stand
up when speaking but no no problem just
to to remind those rules now I give the
floor to Canada
one minute
thank you
thank you Mr President commissioner once
again we are here in this chamber
speaking about one of the worst
discriminations which exists a pay gap
between women and men this we need to
insist and ensure that the principle
over equal pay for equal work is applied
we need to draw paid transparency and
Joint pay assessments moreover it's
important to underscore that European
businesses with over 100 stuff
will have to provide information on
um on salaries
this is something that won't be done
with businesses which have less than 100
workers there'll be no
um additional burden for businesses that
have less than 100 members of Staff the
real situation of smes in Italy a vital
part of the economy will not be
penalized in any way shape or form this
is the path forward to put an end
to this cancer which has been existing
for far too long poisoning the world of
work
thank you very much the next speaker is
Anika Bruner woman please
report is similar to all of the texts we
vote on in the European Parliament often
laudable adjectives but completely
disconnected from reality we cannot
judge a text by its title but looking we
have to do so by looking at the whole
text what about uh company bosses who
are struggling to recover from the
covid-19 pandemic and who are affected
by the current inflation crisis what we
are doing is we are adding an
administrative burden to their work
you are imposing more standards on
companies publishing information and
reports and the burden of proof is on
the employer
if we want to achieve pay equality for
men and women we cannot accept that our
business owners be the victim of these
decisions thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Francis Fitzgerald the Overflow
president commissioner Dali colleagues
I'd like to thank all the MEPS who've
worked so cooperatively on this file to
ensure we're at this moment in time here
today for the Epp Maria Walsh and Sir
Papa Peter Cannon have put in a huge
amount of workers I know everybody has
this is a fundamental principle of our
democracy equal pay for equal work this
has been one of our guiding principles
in gender equality since the foundation
of our Union yet we've never realized it
in reality we've been behind but today
we are on the cusp of great historical
change
this legislation to close to finally
close the gender pay Gap will be a game
changer the 12.6 pay Gap that still
exists not to mention the 39 pension Gap
uh hopefully uh will be reduced and will
be no more in the time ahead
this directive will promote gender paid
transparency across Europe meaning it is
good for women but it is also very very
good for business there is a huge loss
to Ouran economies from the lack of
gender equality and we have to focus on
this more and more by disclosing the
gender pay Gap at company 11 we can get
to the root of the problem we can see
exactly what's going on and already
we've seen changes when you have this
transparency and they're very surprising
some of the data that's emerging let me
say from companies you wouldn't expect
to see it from so it's very important we
have waited far too long for this today
we are showing that we are standing for
the right for women to be treated
equally in Europe thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much I know I'd give the
floor to Vera tax for one minute please
foreign
thousand Euros you win it on the lottery
what would you do would you buy a car
would you buy a house well this is
um what you need to do you need to work
to earn that money how are the
the half of us three receive 300 000 as
a bonus throughout our careers
this is what uh men earn more than women
on average over Korea 12 percent more
than
um
than the than women and in Netherlands
it's 14 uh people say that oh this
doesn't happen in my business but the
reality is that there are workers who
want to know what people earn they want
to stop uh this pay Gap and then these
people are sacked this is the reality
this is a reality uh that we need to
change the European Union is going to do
so it's going to do so by changing the
burden of proof it's the business owner
who needs to show that there is no paid
discrimination in their business
in doing so we can change the balance of
power I'd like to thank Kira and Samira
for having achieved this three years
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker
Johann Nissan please
thank you
thank you president
our matters that are outside the EU
competence they are dealt with best at
member level
member state level and I think this the
best possible solution is not a Brussels
solution the transparency directive is
expensive it's complicated it's
bureaucratic and it completely knocks
the legs out from under the Swedish
model where the union and the employers
negotiate and how she how it's up to the
hiring interview to determine the wage
situation and how it should be
communicated so very few people should
be determined uh what it should be
happening for Enterprises throughout the
entire EU and I think this model
applying to all people can be placed
within a few small categories this is a
model that's going to work very poorly
and I don't think it belongs anywhere
other than the waste paper basket
[Applause]
thank you very much and I'd like to give
the floor to our colleague yarislav Duda
thank you very much
president Madame commissioner
I would like to say the long last
because quite recently as I talked to a
colleague I had a feeling that there is
no need to regulate something that is
pretty obvious by implementing a
directive in this respect but as I
listen to some of those voices in this
Hall I see that the directive is in this
in indispensable so I would like to
congratulate the reporters and I'm happy
to see that we are regulating this issue
at the long last it is a huge problem
that in the 21st century we have such a
strong Gap in terms of remunerations
between the genders it's really
very prevalent
I would also like to say that I'm very
happy to see that there is this
step-by-step model which is included in
the draft directive which makes us
hopeful that the respective regulations
will be implemented in the member states
and I also do believe that thanks to due
diligence of the member states and
employers we will never again have to
revisit this issue in this chamber thank
you very much
thank you very much
Mr Duda
from from colleague visionieska
please
thank you very much
Mr Duda
I would like to ask you a question which
relates to the directive itself you've
just said that this directive will lead
to a greater transparency that women
will have greater opportunities you have
been elected in Poland and you will
probably know full well that in Poland
we have one of the lowest pay gaps in
the European Union we've managed without
such regulations
we have a very equal pay for men and
women so wouldn't you be afraid that
this regulation mind might the president
has cut the microphone foreign
thank you very much I would like to
congratulate uh Mrs rafalska on her
statement
it was very good yeah yeah yeah remember
rafalska is in the in the hall yeah I'm
answering your question right now so I'm
quite surprised by a question uh Madame
vishnavska because I'm proud of what is
happening in my country in this respect
because indeed
we do have that with this gender pay Gap
is one of the smallest in Europe This is
the result of many years of work but I
do believe the directive will be
necessary I don't know how you will vote
as ECR but I believe that we do have to
adopt such regulations in this chamber
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr President commissioner
thank you to the rapporters because
today we've taken a significant step
forward in Europe to fight to pay
discrimination against all women in
Europe the pay Gap is around 13 and this
means the the annual Gap in income is a
gap is around 40 this is the higher risk
of poverty
high risk of leaving the labor market to
lower negotiating capacity uh and uh and
a higher efficiency in our labor markets
that's why this pay transparency
directive is a fantastic step forward it
obliges businesses with more than 100
workers to share information to allow
for paid to be compared so that we know
that if a work of equal value is being
paid at the same level for all of those
involved it also ensures that the sexist
criteria cannot be used to set pay
levels if this does happen then um
workers have been discriminated can be
uh compensated it also has
incentives to be set up to ensure people
achieve these roles we are moving
towards a fairer Europe
Finland thank you
the next speaker is Mrs Roth negative
thank you very much for giving me the
floor I consider the adoption of this
directive to be historic finally the EU
will have legislation
that will work against the pay gap
between men and women and it's very
important to Define what equal work
means so it's we can make effective
comparisons so we no longer just hear
that women work less they're weaker and
that's why they deserve less pay I'm
very happy that we have more
transparency now in remuneration
and there's going to be an obligation to
not just publish the amount of the
salary for the positions being offered
but also
a comparison with the
amount between men and women it has to
speak clearly has to be very clear to
see who's really trying and who's just
pretending to be equal there are
countries with anti-discrimination laws
but practice shows that these can be
circumvented and I think this directive
will help us to use the existing laws
more effectively thank you
thank you very much Mrs
now we've moved to catch the i-6 persons
and then the list is closed Mrs Carvalho
is the first
car president
commissioner European women and 13 less
than men for work of the same value they
said discrimination means thousands of
Euros a difference at the end of the
year however the consequences are not
purely economic we cannot undermine the
demotivation that this leads to when
women are not paid for their
qualitization this directive is another
step forward to put an end to gender
discrimination the European People's
Party
will give us full support to this
however we know the success of these
measures it will be linked to their
sustainability that's why we wanted to
introduce Progressive uh amendments for
smes we wanted to ensure that we can uh
win this battle
yeah
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker is Mr olekas
president dear colleagues I call on you
to evaluate the pay difference
differences in rural areas where women
face various challenges the income
opportunities are fewer we should take
into account the infrastructure in rural
areas
on the European level women account
women hold Farms which are 40 percent uh
smaller than those of men and when it
comes to pension Gap the difference is
50 in Lithuania uh women farmers are
responsible for 50 of all Farms but they
receive
their income is much lower uh I think if
we achieve equality in uh agricultural
payments in your EU that would help us
in our Strife for equal for equality
rural areas will become a place
attractive for women farmers
thank you
no Mr hogwain
yeah
thank you very much president
I think it's important to perhaps
counteract some of this pessimism
because in women in Europe women are
doing very well
in education for instance
women have over taken men sixty percent
of dentists and doctors are women six 75
percent
in child education
more than 80 percent
in higher education
it's true
that men have a lesser training there's
more cases of school failure so
inequality is a widespread phenomenon
and we need to combat This Together by
improving assistance for younger people
and in nurseries
thank you very much
one minute
Mrs Pereira
thank you president uh
once again we have a directive and this
is highly expected but it doesn't move
forward significantly when we fight
pages but a disparity between men and
women at times it can legitimize them
and extend them this is in relation to
the five percent uh of uh average uh so
there is some disparity is acceptable
why is that however it won't be uh in
support to the rights of women in my
country the idea of uh equal pay for
equal work is something that is well
anchored but it's not
um it's seen in reality because there is
no political support for it and we often
see subcontracting as an excuse for
different uh
um pay levels in reality this proposal
undermines the position the European
Parliament and doesn't fight this
Brussels neoliberalism will not help to
significantly move forward the situation
of those women who are working and above
all those on low salaries
feed them
thank you
the next speaker
is Mrs Novak
thank you very much for the floor chair
equal pay for equal work this should be
a given we shouldn't even have to
discuss this issue because it has to be
clear if we are carrying out an equal
work we have to be equally paid it is
more questionable the next issue how are
we gonna Define uh work of equal value
because unfortunately there are
professions that are not equally paid
many women for example are cleaners and
jobs like these are not respected enough
that is why there are enormous
differences in payments between men and
women and this of course reflects in the
old age when women have lower pensions
when more women are widows because they
live longer than men and because of it
we are also facing a huge problem when
every honest job is honestly and fairly
he paid this pay should be sufficient
for a decent living
thank you Mrs Novak to conclude the
discussion Mrs capini
College
commissioner colleagues
debating something which appears to be
normal but what has surprised me has
been the perspective of certain
colleagues that who believe that we do
not need this legislation they believe
that everything is fine
that's fine everything's fine between
employers and trade unions and it would
create more red tape well I can say I
come from the private sector and today
there is a difference between men and
women when it comes to doing the same
work and the pay
democracy
the voluntary rules are not being
respected therefore it's essential that
we have this directive everybody needs
to understand that there should be no
pay differences
no we're not talking about just about
the situation of cleaning ladies we need
to have the same pay for the same work
and for this reason I will be voting in
favor of this directive however it needs
to be implemented in member states and
we need to monitor that to make sure
that it is done foreign
thank you Mrs capini
to conclude the discussion we have the
commissioner and the two repertoires so
on behalf of the commission Mrs dally
thank you president honorable members
the adoption of the directive on paid
transparency will benefit all workers
and all businesses in Europe
together we need to raise awareness
about this new directive to ensure that
workers know their rights and that
employers understand their obligations
in addition this directive will
contribute towards economic growth and
competitiveness
closed agenda pay pension and employment
gap in line with the social pillar
action plan
value women's contribution to the labor
market and make sure that women are not
left behind in the Twin green and
digital transition
and the current climate of post-pandemic
Crisis the war against Ukraine High
Energy prices and inflation it is even
more important the gender responsive
approaches are at the center of building
the future of the Union of equality
paying women and men equally should be
part of our response
so I thank again the reporters
all the MEPS who have worked for this
day I see Evelyn here Maria Vera dragos
Mark but but many many more of course
and also I thank the the Czech
presidency for having achieved a
successful result and the European
Parliament for your ongoing support
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Mrs Dali
Mrs Rafaela is next
thank you dear colleagues for your
support and the valuable contributions
you know I'm not going to waste any time
anymore in this house to explain that we
have gender inequality in Europe I'm
just not gonna do that anymore I'm gonna
fix it because it needs attention it
needs time to fix gender inequality
the administrative burden for companies
are here really you want to talk
business there is a well-known report in
the Netherlands from McKinsey saying
that the Dutch economy is losing
billions because of the lack of gender
equality administrative burden while
you're losing billions come on
the statistics show 13 percent
can the pay Gap in Europe that's the
statistics here and it's significant
what's your solution contribute to the
solution that
fix the issue then because it's still 13
and we're still talking now we are
really doing something it's the very
first step to close the gender pay Gap
and it's a right it's a European right
it's in our treaties to treat to treat
men and and women equal
so I don't understand the issue here and
I'm very proud because this legislation
is Progressive it's modern it's feminist
it's liberal it's intersectional so
today is a good day and I'm gonna
celebrate I'm gonna celebrate because we
have true legislation in place from now
to give women their rights specifically
to be paid on an equal basis
so I'm going to celebrate big time
because it's a good day for women in
Europe thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mrs Rafaela to conclude the
discussion the rapporteur Mrs Peter
Hansen again Samira for your retired
efforts for to fight for for women and
all kinds of women and thank you very
much colleagues for all of your remarks
I'm extremely happy that we are finally
voting a disagreement and that we move
forward with this important piece of
legislation I Envision a future where
employees are valued for their work
regardless of their agenda a future
where employees know their rights and
they are not afraid to exercise them
because they know that they are
protected by European law
the future is here we have achieved that
and we finally have patrons parented
tools to combat pay discrimination
gender income inequalities and to
empower workers so I look forward
through the vote and I'm going to
celebrate as well and I hope that this
whole house is thank you very much
in Denver
thank you Mrs Peter Hansen the debate is
closed the vote will be held today after
the next dossier
the next point on the agenda The Joint
debate concerning rule of law
it concerns a commission statement on
the
2022 rule of law report rule of law in
Europe
as well as concerning rule of law and
Greece rule of law in Spain and rule of
law in Malta